[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen wohnkomplex mit
bandnudeln hackfleisch und spiral nudeln
und zwar auf gemüse
ich habe heute dieses wort rezept
vorbereitet denn es schmeckt sehr lecker
ohne viel blut hatten
ich brauche dafür drei esslöffel
olivenöl 500 gramm rinder hat fleisch
eines regel eine knoblauchzehe eine
zucchini wird 400 gramm habe ich
karotten dessen 300 500 verband mode
nämlich 150 gramm frisch gebe etwas
pfeffer einen habe ich noch gewürze
jeweils einem teelöffel oregano
basilikum eine prise zucker und chili
250 gramm kleine tomaten 50 gramm und
etwas vom sagte den topf sich jetzt mit
dem olivenöl
während es hier noch warm wird kann ich
schon mal geschrieben
die zwiebel fein hacken darin kann ich
anbraten
und während das hackfleisch andere kann
ich schon mal das filmen so weiter
verarbeiten
und zwar weil dieses jahr aus spirale
der nudeln machen und nehme zwar für den
ferrari auf falsche gesetzt habt könnt
ihr zum beispiel einfach mit einem
gemüse fehler kleine dünne scheiben
abschlag abschalten kann ich jetzt den
mittelgroßen aufsatz dafür und jetzt
könnt ihr da die karotte und die
zurückliegende reinstecken muss gerade
wegen der größe vorboten des entführten
man schrieb man das nach vorne und
steckt sie aber treiben und den rest
erledigt die maschine
[Musik]
und macht es bleibt ist dieser charakter
und das immer dabei karotte am liebsten
[Musik]
beide faktoren ich gebraten ist kommen
da die zwiebel und knoblauch würfel mit
flug und werden so etwa eine minute zwei
mit gerührt
[Musik]
zum abzweig gebe ich jetzt noch ein
fehler dazu
der macht das ganze sonnencreme ich bin
ruhig auch ein bisschen runter gestellt
und jetzt möchte ich das ganze mit
wasser ab und vergebt jetzt erstmal nur
500 milliliter in etwa auf kochen und
dann kommen nämlich tag gleich die nudel
metapher
wir geben jetzt auch schon mal die
gewürze mit dazu
[Musik]
und sobald die soße braucht kann ich
jetzt viel nudeln das so geben und
warten jetzt ganz klar für ein bisschen
weich werden das ist gleich gut
durchrühren kann
dafür gebe ich jetzt gleich den deckel
drauf und lass' mir dann so etwa 15
minuten kochen initiative umzustellen
und auch auf die packungsanleitung
schauen wenn wir nach mittelwerte
brauchen wir doch länger oder kürzer
aber ich werd des nix ist kochen
[Musik]
also ich bin jetzt noch gut geht und er
früher einmal ihr könnt jetzt an der
stelle auch schon abschnitten mit salz
und pfeffer hier bei mir muss noch mit
dem wasser rein und jetzt kommt's an
dieser stelle auch das gemüse mir das
vor
damit einfach noch schön knackig bleibt
eine große portion
[Musik]
wobei die karotte gerne ein bisschen
weißer markt schon bei drei minuten
vorher mit dazu ich möchte allerdings
gern filme knacken und vier habe ich
schon ein bisschen sesam und den rest in
der pfanne ohne fett dann ist nur
aufpassen aber nicht verbrennen
[Musik]
und am ende ist alles noch mal gut durch
und baku ist auch die tomaten und wenn
sie auch gerne etwas weiter beispiel
einfach vorher meter zu geben
pfeffer würzen und bonität noch eine
ordentliche prise salz
[Musik]
zum schluss dem ich jetzt noch vor allen
dingen könnt ihr entweder über die
gesamte portion machen oder auch jeder
individuell
ich mache kein bissl was ihr dazu und
der punkt noch mal richtig schön
wirksamer 3
[Applaus]
[Musik]
model
und nochmal ein bisschen parmesan und am
veto
[Musik]
okay wer verstanden hat schreibt einfach
herz zeigt den herrscher hier unten
damit ist nicht da ist werden hier alle
probieren ob eine gabel
ich finde jedenfalls da das gericht
frisch auf mit dem teure leckeren gemüse
kommt man nur nudeln voll schön damit so
viel und spielen meine ganze gabe von
nur mit zucchini mein gott
darunter computer also ich finde richtig
lecker und knackig und frisch wir haben
langsam auch echt gut in kombination mit
dem parmesan fall nicht ganz so lange
spirale nudel haben wollt könnt ihr ja
vorher das gemüse entwicklung führt
verschneiden dann werden auch die
spirale ist natürlich ein bisschen
krippe habe ich natürlich vorher
vergessen war haben wir zwei meter lange
spirale mit denen die anwälte kämpfen
hat und weil sie dieses leckere rezepte
machen wollt dann jeder freundlich -
software steht für euch und ich wünsche
euch allen ganz viel spaß dabei und
einen guten appetit
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
und bei mir sieht noch eine ordentliche
prise santen